a ella se le acredita la histórica
decisión que tomó al tribunal supremo
que estableció el derecho al aborto en
eeuu sarah weddington ella que argumentó
con éxito el caso roe versus weight de
1973 junto a otra abogada linda coffee
juntas presentaron una demanda colectiva
contra el fiscal de distrito del condado
de wallace hendry weight en nombre de
una mujer embarazada que impugnó una ley
de texas que prohibía la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo el tribunal
supremo dictaminó en su momento que la
constitución estadounidense
garantizaba el derecho de la mujer al
aborto y que los estados no podían
privarles de ese derecho durante casi 50
años el derecho al aborto en eeuu se ha
basado en esta jurisprudencia que sigue
siendo la base legal de referencia sin
que se haya aprobado ninguna ley federal
ya a finales de los 90 la gran
arquitecta del derecho al aborto usará
weddington advirtió de las amenazas a
este derecho fundamental
amenazas que sigue empresa en todo el
país por ejemplo el 10 de diciembre el
tribunal supremo se negó a bloquear una
ley de texas que entró en vigor el 1º de
septiembre y que prohíbe a las mujeres
abortar después de seis semanas de
embarazo